that question is I have trouble finding a comfortable sleeping position is
okay to position the right bulb under your pillow um yes you can it partly
depends on where your cancer is technically you want the right is close to your
cancer as possible if you're lying on your side put the put the bulb behind you
or in front of you I still think it's probably better
and getting your whole body more if it's more by your side it doesn't have to be
touching you remember um if it's within six to 12 inches that's great
if you did if you are stuggling with it it is touching you that's better
but don't worry if it falls if you move around and you have to set it by your
side or whatever don't worry about that if you put it under your pillow it's
Bailey um I mean it's I I guess you can I would think that would be highly
uncomfortable but um if you're putting if you're thinking to put it
on that you're putting it under your pillow and it's above your head so it's
not affected your flexion of your neck um on your lower dorses of your cervical
spine then I would say that it's getting farther away from you so um
but whatever works if that works better that's I think that's fine too